ces images apocalyptique ont été filmées
le 13 août dernier à force Miss au nord
du Canada le ciel a littéralement viré
au rouge au-dessus de cette commune des
Territoires du Nord-Ouest une région
nordique dévorée depuis mai par des feux
de forêt incontrôlables 230 brasiers
sont dans ce moment actifs dans la
région qui est grande comme deux fois la
France métropolitaine et ses feux
continuent de progresser hier soir la
principale ville du Grand Nord canadien
yellow knife a reçu l'ordre d'évacuer
ses 20 000 résidents le brasier est à 20
km de ces murs malheureusement la
situation des feux de forêt tourne au
pire avec un brasier à l'ouest de Yellow
knife qui représente une véritable
menace par les airs ou par la route la
population est sommet de quitter les
lieux car sans pluie il se peut que le
brasier frappe les environs de la ville
ce week-end selon les autorités
territoriales séparées de plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres les uns des
autres les villages de cette région sont
particulièrement difficiles à évacuer
par voie terrestre selon le service des
feux territoriales or les fronts de
flammes se déplacent très vite et
peuvent faire jusqu'à plusieurs
kilomètres de large rendant la lutte
très complexe pour les pompiers un
contingent de l'armée canadienne a même
dû être pour participer aux évacuations
aériennes l'autoroute était engloutie
par les flammes je ne pouvais rien voir
devant moi il n'y avait plus de réseau
donc aucun moyen de savoir où j'étais
c'était le moment le plus effrayant de
ma vie c'est le témoignage de Jordan
Evoy 28 ans habitant d'une petite
municipalité actuellement sous ordre
d'évacuation ce lundi il espérait
quitter son domicile en voiture pour se
réfugier en Alberta province mitoyenne
mais prise au piège par les flammes et
craignant de voir ses pneus fondre il a
dû rebrousser chemin et évacuer via un
avion militaire après la capitale
territoriale yellow knife c'est
l'ensemble de la région des Territoires
du Nord-Ouest qui a décrété l'état
d'urgence mardi soir la situation évolue
rapidement les besoins sur le terrain
change vite souligne le gouvernement qui
assure utiliser tous les outils à sa
disposition pour faire face à l'urgence
j'ai le cœur brisé en pensant aux gens
des TNO aux prises avec des feux de
forêt dévastateurs la province voisine
de la colombe britannique elle aussi
durement frappée par les feux de forêt a
enregistré des températures au-delà des
40 degrés Celsius une première cette
année pour le pays au total plus de 13
millions d'hectares sont partis en fumée
dans l'ensemble du Canada depuis le
début de l'année et près de 168 000
personnes ont dû être évacuées par sa
situation géographique ce pays
d'Amérique du Nord se réchauffe plus
vite que le reste de la planète ces
dernières années il est confronté à des
événements météorologiques extrêmes dont
l'intensité et la fréquence tant à
augmenter
[Musique]